hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check this week saw the release of rise
of the Tomb Raider the latest in the oh
so famous archaeological adventure
franchise so this episode brought to you
by our friends at Xbox is going to
celebrate the gaming icon that is Lara
Croft and when you think about it
Lara Croft isn't like most video game
protagonists in that she doesn't really
have any kind of magical or superhuman
abilities she can't cast bees out of her
hands like Jack from Bioshock or channel
electricity like Cole McGraw she can't
even devour the souls of dragons come on
Lara get it together
everyone can absorb dragon souls she's
just an ordinary person so how the hell
can she do all of the things that she
does she certainly falls down a lot gets
impaled on things a lot and has to enjoy
a hell of a lot of physical exertion
there's obviously some element of video
game movie magic but overall Lara's just
a plain old non-mutated non alien human
being so could a real-life person become
the Tomb Raider and how do Lara's skills
make her such a badass warrior let's
find out now obviously there's various
incarnations of Lara from the rather
pointy original to the admittedly quite
awkward / terrifying teenage Lara and of
course the brand-new rebooted version as
rise of the Tomb Raider just came out
let's use reboot Lara for the purposes
of this video so let's start with
Fitness admittedly the most exercise I
get is walking to and from the couch so
if I wanted to take up to Maury ting
full-time what would I have to do well
we know that Lara is extremely fit
primarily because she did gymnastics in
her youth and while you may think dead
lifting weights is the best way to build
up those glutes Hamza is doom nastic is
actually an incredibly effective way of
building strength power and flexibility
on top of that crucially you learn
balance and control all of these do
wonders for those pixel-perfect leaps
and delicate dodging while navigating
crumbly old tombs strength is also key
when climbing which you may notice Lara
has to do a lot of she brings together
two different kinds of climbing
Styles free soloing and bouldering free
soloing is where the climate scales
heights without using any ropes or
harnesses which most of the time is what
lard does but when climbing tombs you
could say that she's actually doing
bouldering now bouldering also doesn't
use any ropes on harnesses and it's
actually more like solving a puzzle than
just following a path a route from A to
B in bouldering is even called a problem
so you're not just using your muscles
you're using your brain
- another thing Lara has in abundance is
resourceful nurse which is key when
you're scrambling around in
long-forgotten wastes of course Lara
spent most of her youth travelling with
her father on exciting expeditions now
these weren't just sightseeing trips but
full on many adventures that would make
Indiana Jones jealous and as a child she
was frequently left in the care of
professional treasure hunter and
ex-military man Conrad Roth so not only
was she learning about ancient
civilizations and archaeological smarts
she was picking up key survival skills
like how to make a campfire how do you
salvage to craft items and crucially her
way around a weapon or two while
magically combining mushrooms to make
poisonous gas clouds maybe drops into
the realm of video game magic the
ability to craft and utilize items like
Molotov and bandages proves pretty
useful - Lara's success but the key
thing that helps Lara and joy is her
survival instinct you know that bit in
the game where time slows down and
everything goes black and white okay so
in real life we can't just fiddle with
the passage of time but that
fight-or-flight response that gives Lara
the edge is a totally real thing a
primitive automatic response to when our
body thinks that there's a threat to our
survival and it's actually kind of crazy
what happens nav start firing in the
brain which starts flooding up let's
stream with hormones like adrenaline
noradrenaline and cortisol we start
breathing faster blood gets redirected
away from secondary operations like
digestion and into our muscles giving us
extra energy to fight run or dodge bears
our impulses quicken perfect to leap
over a spike pit at the last minute we
feel less pain but crucially for a Tomb
Raider our eyesight sharpens in the game
at least this works out that key items
in the environment glow whether it be
crafting materials or relics to pick up
or even keep ease
of scenery so when you think about it
regardless of Lara's top education
extracurricular activities love of
climbing and lifetime of adventure the
thing that really makes her the world's
best Tomb Raider and an overall
excellent warrior is the most basic
thing in the world that we all have and
I for one think that that's pretty cool
just a quick bit of news before I go
reality check is moving don't worry
we're not going very far
we're just moving from Sunday's to
Thursday's right here on youtube.com
slash GameSpot it'll be alternating with
that other show what I do in two minutes
so Thursday is basically Lucy day I
should get some branding made make sure
to look out for a brand new show
featuring those kind of funny folks
called things you missed where they're
elf I spot hidden secrets from all the
latest announcements thanks for watching
and reality check we'll be back in a
couple weeks
on Thursday see you then